[Music]
alright let's talk about consciousness a
little bit I just had Sam Harris on
we've talked about it quite extensively
I think you have some thoughts on
consciousness the nature of
consciousness indeed yeah I mean it's
probably to do this right we would need
to agree on a definition and I'm not
sure that that's any definition that we
choose will immediately untag and I some
amount of your audience right this is
like the active way this is like
defining truth which seems to be tough
these days yes exactly so maybe maybe
rather than that your are humans the
only conscious beings on this planet I
don't think so but we are the most
conscious we are the most fully
conscious and we have better access to
our own consciousness obviously then we
have access to the consciousness of say
dolphins or elephants or other apes or
maybe wolves any of these long-lived
social organisms with long childhoods
and generational overlap who lived
sometimes with three generations
together at a time so this transmission
of cultural information organisms that
have theory of mind and can imagine can
put themselves in the other individuals
position and think what do they think is
going on right now even though I
understand that that's a different thing
than what I think is going on right now
right which we now know that certain
monkeys and apes exactly do that
yes theory of mind there's a beautiful
book called baboon metaphysics by the
husband and wife team Cheney and
Seyfarth that basically explores theory
of mind in baboons and you know it's
it's not the only one they're not the
only species but you know how do we as
humans find our consciousness best you
know there there are ways that we can
hack into what does some has been called
flow States or you know that's that's
the most common one but you know we can
do so through well through deep
conversation through meditation through
music some sometimes through producing
it but sometimes to experiencing
especially live music mm-hmm
dance for some people
hallucinogens sex sport you know intense
physical or physiological or emotional
experience in which we are just moving
with others usually and you know there
are those of us like myself you know
very strong introvert who will refined
so my deepest flow space you know access
to consciousness alone you alone in the
Amazon when I could sit and watch
monkeys and write nothing for me that's
one of them what sport is also so when I
talked about this with Sam the way he
was defining it which i think is sort of
similar to what you're saying here it
strikes me as just like an extreme
ability to maintain present in the
moment that that really sort of win a
basketball player so if we use the sport
analogy like a basketball third when
they're in the zone you know and Jordan
scores 20 points in five minutes and he
just he go he said well everything I
threw up just went in like right that
they hit that level of consciousness or
for you to be outside enough out of
yourself to be able to write in that
perfect moment or whatever does but it
always seems about being present more
than anything else do there is a kind of
time stopping both times stopping and
disappearing on you at the same time
which i think is part of why antigens
hallucinogens can capture that as well
because there the sense of time just
disappearing on you is is remarkable so
you you both don't care about time and
time passes usually in ways that seem
quicker than you're affecting them to
with with say sports or or right
meditation right you know that's not one
of it I do but you know Sam has a lot to
say about that if yes yeah I remember
when I was doing mushrooms at least
college-age somewhat consistently maybe
every six months or something I would
always want the clocks to be covered yes
because I I hated the they're no good I
did I definitely did one trip like five
hours in a mirror forget that but I
always wanted the clocks to be covered
because the idea that time was passing
while I was in this yes state was was
very scary to me now that's scary or
just I just wanted nothing to do with it
I guess
right and that you know it's
maybe it doesn't matter what that
distinction is you know scary or just
not interested right but so it's it's
very different the the kinds of
consciousness enhancing activities that
we can engage in including hallucinogens
are very different if you're inside in a
room like this where you have no access
to what is going on climatologically or
weather wise outside as opposed to if
you if you are out and you can watch as
the Sun sets and as the moon comes up
and you can think again oh right it's a
it's a it's a waxing moon and it'll be
full in four days and or you know or or
you're at a coast and you can watch the
tides and think about the shifting time
so for me thinking about time that is
clearly being brought it's clearly being
revealed by the planet we're on as
opposed to coming at me through a clock
is more meaningful and I'm what I'm
willing to think about time in that way
but definitely not through clocks when
I'm when I'm writing hallucinogens sport
any of that right right and yet we have
all of these devices now that are meant
our time that are meant to take our
attention that are literally designed
this way do you sense Ron's like that
there's actually a digital assault on
consciousness because maybe that really
does explain so many of the other
problems we're having in society right
now it's it's one of the key pieces for
sure and I think that phrase is
brilliant a digital assault on
consciousness this is something just on
Harris who I don't know but yeah I've
got him on the show yeah
talks talks about a lot and you know
he's been he has been ringing the alarm
bell for years about the algorithms that
are being put into our devices that are
that are creating addicts out of us no
but more broadly
you know the digital assault
unconsciousness is there's not there is
it's increasingly hard to find a space
where you're just actually free and
clear and this is you know this is part
of what I do for myself and what I used
to do for my students was take them to
places not only that were remote and
where they could explore nature but
where there was no cell signal where
there was no internet so you know the
deepest part of the Amazon that I took
students to there's just there's no
email
there's no internet there's no Wi-Fi we
are you know a plane ride over the Andes
and then a boat ride and then a truck
ride and then another five hours down a
tributary of the Amazon to a place with
no roads no air strips nothing and boy
does time feel different and you know
you're sleeping in little cabins that
are screened and so you wake up when the
insects and the birds and the monkeys
wake up and they start talking at you
there I can't you they're talking
themselves but you getting a sense of
the rhythms of the planet that we're on
can return people I think to a real
sense of self and also to a sense of
what they value what their passions are
and this is a big thing I think is
missing in many of the to return to what
we were talking about earlier you know
the the far-left activists that the
control left mostly I think lack another
passion and I've said before I you know
the prediction I would make is that you
have very few rock climbers or skiers
among the radical left activists people
who have something that they can engage
in that frees them from time and devices
from from a response to time I need to
be here then or this my thing just
pinged at me I need to look at it are
better able to Center themselves to to
find their own consciousness and
discover who who they are and what they
want to be in the world what does that
say about the self do you think like it
to me there's something there about like
if you really believe in the self and
your and the individual and your ability
to overcome things you don't need all
these external processes to help define
the world because you're sort of
defining it yourself
I agree and I think I do think for me
self sufficiency is one of my highest
values personally and I have a I have a
very hard time understanding anyone who
says oh if you leave me on my own I
wouldn't know what to do
I just don't get this I don't get why
you would maybe the lefty thing I'd be
fine feel like what why would why would
you broadcast to the world that you
would be helpless this doesn't make any
sense to me
but and you know they're they're playing
situations where I wouldn't know what to
do and I would know what to do
in situations that most people wouldn't
just because of where I've traveled and
where I've lived but the idea that
self-sufficiency requite the idea that
you want to be self-sufficient requires
a concept of self I think is is
important here yeah maybe just maybe
that yeah and if you give that up well
then boy you're given a lot you you give
up so much and the devices as as Heron s
Tristan Harris has argued are addicting
us it's no accident you know we should
not view ourselves actually as weak we
when we get addicted to the things we
should Wiener selves we should as much
as possible to provide ourselves zones
periods of time when we have no access
to those things and so we are actually
free and clear to let our minds do what
they will because when when we have when
they have access to our brands they are
designed to attack does so using using
the discipline that you're an expert in
is it possible that we're in a unique
position right now because of technology
that our brains are actually evolving
now evolving or I guess devolving
depending on which way you look at it at
an extraordinarily high pace or
something like that you know yeah the
the rate of change across almost every
sector in the economy and in human
experience right now is higher than it's
ever been
could you say that about any moment in
history maybe but the rate of change
itself is changing right as well right
so that's the important distinction
right and what is going on with
technology is completely untested and so
this is this is a place where you know
why why am I so certain that I'm still
on the left even though most of the
people who say they're on the left
publicly I don't have any interest in
continuing to talk to them because they
don't seem to be making any sense
I look at systems that are involved that
are that are in stable state because
they've evolved over millions tens of
millions hundreds of millions of years
and my instinct is don't mess with that
until you really really understand
you're doing and so for instance I
unlike many scientists I'm not feeding
my children GMOs I mean I give them and
myself organic food and when we meet
which we do a lot of I want that meat to
have been fed the grass of its and the
food of its ancestors mm-hmm what are
what exactly is the harm we now know a
little bit of this but twenty years ago
if you had asked me what's the harm in
feeding cows grains so I have no idea
but I know that messing with a system
that was working is more likely to
interfere with something in that animal
than not mm-hmm why you know why would
you mess if you could not and of course
there are economic reasons to mess but
the the don't mess with systems that are
working until you really have a saw an
understanding of what the what the
effects are going to be the the use of
the precautionary principle pretty
widely yes is what puts me pretty far on
the left but systems that we created
that are evolutionary but people don't
know that we need to regulate in order
to get them under control because
nuclear energy isn't going to regulate
itself and habitat loss throughout most
of the world is not going to regulate
itself so there are some problems that
we've created and that are bigger than
individuals can do anything about and
you know that's why I'm not a
libertarian Yeah right and this is this
is where I think we have a I get it like
I don't know that if you just leave
everybody to do whatever the hell they
want all the time that everybody isn't
going to be doing all sorts of awful
things I think generally the market does
fix some of that but I get what you're
saying like these systems are I suppose
often precarious in nature to to the
point where anything could be tilted one
way or the other and then then we've got
bigger problems right so how do we how
do we fix some of this stuff how do we
how do we actually scale this back I
mean I get it you know most of my
audience will get okay well we have to
keep talking about it sure we have to
wake more people up sure but what can
you do
using the the knowledge you have and the
study you've done I have less I have
less insight right now at least to
answer in this amount of time for the
adult systems but I think I have a fair
amount of clarity on what we should do
should be doing with children and with
parenting okay
really really not doing which is when
you say the adult systems you mean like
economic systems well it's just like and
and more specifically how do you get
adults who are already who they are to
behave differently it's it's less clear
to me what what we can do and okay so
will will shell them for the purpose yes
and you know and the cyst is also also
it's true that I have that I'm not gonna
wade into for instance what we should do
a better economic system here now when
you I might do it later but yeah okay
but with regard to for instance you know
most most people I think have never
thought about what childhood is and if
you don't have children yourself and
you're an adult okay maybe you don't
have to maybe it doesn't matter like
maybe it just doesn't matter to you but
if you're a parent you need to think
about why it is that we have literally
the longest childhood relative to life
span of any organism on the planet this
is a feature this is a way for us to
learn how to become humans we are not
and this is this is a point the Brett
has made very often we're not playing
slates but we are the blackest slates of
any organisms on the planet we we are
more software than hardware and so what
we're doing for these first I don't know
11 to 25 years of our lives right now in
just four days I think but depending on
culture you know when do you start
calling yourself an adult in the Ronis
what we're doing is learning how to be
human and we're learning how to be human
by directing supposed to be learning how
to be human
through instructor direct instructional
by our parents through observing our
parents through observing our siblings
through interacting with including
fighting with our siblings and having
them smack us down both sometimes
literally but definitely metaphorically
when we do stupid things and better yet
if our parents have lots of adult
friends around and they have lots of
kids and there's a whole mess of
humanity that we are learning from and
then we're also in that very long
developmental period supposed to be
learning from direct physical experience
of the world so the example I like to go
to here is
you know the Roadrunner cartoons when
Wiley coyote
scoots his way off a cliff mm-hmm and he
doesn't fall until he realizes there's
nothing below him it's funny right like
it's really funny but of course it's
funny because we know that gravity
doesn't really work that way right
increasingly I suspect that a lot of
kids and now into origin and and some of
the younger Millennials kind of aren't
sure like they were protected so much by
their helicopter parents and they were
behind screens rather than having real
experience and to the extent that they
played sport it was totally regulated
and overseen by adults and they didn't
have any free time to go and get
themselves into trouble and maybe even
like burn something down or hurt
themselves or break an arm or whatever
it is and learn from it that they
arrived at the cusp of what should have
been adulthood totally unclear on what
that's supposed to mean does this
absolutely to you because as I'm hearing
you say that this is might the bell
going off in my head man I've been on
tour Peterson for the last six weeks
everything that you just said there is
basically what he is saying he is trying
to I sense that what he's trying to do
at the most personal level yeah he talks
about society as a whole but at the most
personal level he's trying to retool
young people it's not even retool he's
trying to give them the tools in the
first place that they clearly should
have gotten before so that's what's so
fascinating to me because it's like how
did this happen right how did how did
this happen and you know we can point to
we can point to pharmaceuticals being
given to kids to make boys less boy like
and to some degree to make girls less
girl like you know give great let's give
speed to boys so they'll sit and face
forward and learn what so they'll come
down what do rough and tumble play and I
mean that's insane yeah and at the same
time let's give anti-anxiety meds to
girls and SSRIs and and you know just
just the model of schooling is
ridiculous you know we have we have
schools that have gotten rid of recess
because recess is dangerous and when
everyone who has ever been in school
even if like me you
happened to have been a good fit for the
model of schools that you were in which
i think is pretty rare actually knows
that you also need to have time to get
out there and play and move your body
and experience it and not have it being
overseen by some adult who's decided in
advance what is and is not safe for you
to experience so you know one of the
things I used to say to my students in
advance you know I did a lot of team
building and like actual team building
and planning with them in advance of
these long study abroad trips we would
have spent weeks together on campus in
advance of going on these trips but what
I wanted to do before we left was
established with them what's your
relationship with risk how do you how do
you view yourself your relationship with
risk and we would do this in around like
and I would answer the question too and
you know I would say to them actually I
happen to love risk I will I am the
leader on this trip but I will keep all
of you safe but then I'm gonna go do
things and you know I like I am going to
walk alone in the forest a lot and do
things because it happens to be one of
the ways that I find my consciousness
that night that I find my truest self
and I don't expect any of you to do that
also but you need to be comfortable with
the fact that your leader is going to be
doing that sort of thing and one of the
other things that we would talk about
was you know what's your relationship
with comfort you're gonna be
uncomfortable you could have to you know
just because you can say in advance
you're okay with the bugs and the mud
and they're not having a phone doesn't
mean you actually will be raised with it
but maybe most important is we are going
to leave ourselves open to serendipity I
cannot tell you everything that we are
going to do or learn on this trip if I
could what would be the point of going
we're gonna go and some interesting
things are going to happen I've I've had
a couple of near-death experiences on
these trips I didn't want them made you
know I and you know I was there's a
learning experience for you there's a
learning experience and frankly on the
most recent one on a on a boat in the
Galapagos with eight students in which
the only thing that didn't survive was
the boat but it was it was really touch
and go I mean I really did almost die
those eight students and I are friends
for life right you know there's there's
some of them that I'm not an active
contact with but I I know where they are
and that you know that bonds you and no
I'm not gonna pitch a trip with and you
might die that's not what the goal is
but the idea that it could happen and
you should have the tools on board the
physical tools the psychological tools
the emotional tools intellectual tools
to figure out in a real time as your
boat is being flipped by a 15-foot wave
and now you're trapped under it what do
you do with that a uniquely evergreen
type of teaching was that saying that
you and Brett really that was a union
there me kind of teaching and this last
trip Brett was there with me as well
there was there was a way in which I
think what I said about childhood which
I you know my interest originally in
evolution was about the evolution of
parental care and territoriality and
social systems and sexual selection and
long before I ever had kids myself long
before I wanted kids but I thought you
know once Brett and I did have kids and
I'm watching these amazing creatures
begin to grow up okay let's think then
about what what is the best way to to do
this and we could put them in little
boxes and make absolutely sure that they
survive till the age of eighteen and
then we open up the boxes and we let
them out and they have basically no
chance of being adults or even of
knowing how to be adults mm-hmm or we
could expose them to ever greater risk
having first made absolutely sure that
they know that they are loved and that
we have their backs and that we will do
anything to come in and get them and to
protect them if we can but that they are
going to start going out into the world
pretty early
you know biking it too and you know we
took them to the Amazon at 7 and 9 the
first time and you know something could
have gone wrong and I don't know
I've known parents who lost kids and I
don't know how you survived that but you
need to be willing to take risks such
that when your kids do hit 18 or 20 or
whatever you know that they're actually
already on their way to being adults and
that is going to require backing off and
letting them do some of their learning
their own and knowing that that's going
to result in some harm coming to them
and it's gonna be physical harm it's
gonna be psychological harm it's gonna
be intellectual harm but frankly the the
lack of any kind of harm that a lot of
kids are experiencing is part of why
they're now saying speech is violence
yeah right I mean that's that's part of
how we get there is some of this an
extension of the success of the West in
a way because if you take the this set
of kids who however old they are let's
say we go from although now there's a
lot of studies that are showing that
young the generation younger than
Millennials is actually leaning more
conservative but let's say we take
sixteen to thirty roughly yeah so
Generation Y ish that you could that
most of their parents were baby boomers
who were the most successful at least
financially generation ever most of the
baby boomers parents all went to war and
you know lived through depression and
all sorts of but that because the baby
boomer is basically were the biggest
middle class and because there was such
upward mobility they had it so well they
kind of got their eye off the ball
started focusing on things that didn't
matter as much protecting kids from
things that a kid would have used to
have to have done and that is sort of
what led us here so it's almost like an
economic backing for what ended up
happening psychologically yeah I think I
think that's apt you know there's so
many things feeding into this and yes
the wealth of America post-world war ii
and the fact that those are mostly the
parents of the generation that seems the
most confused
I think definitely there's a causal link
there yeah and then you toss in the
Internet and you toss on the Internet
right which yeah we can't go back
obviously but but we need to understand
that it's an evolutionary system and
then it's going to run away from us and
that we are all prone to be addicted to
dopamine hits we're going to seek the
quick but quick likes rather than you
know even even okay so take Internet out
of the picture for a moment if you I
don't know what you do for physical
activity I bike you play basketball
so maybe with basketball it's going to
be different for me
I like videogames too is that better no
yes that's probably so I used to play a
lot of Ultimate Frisbee and you could oh
like anytime there's a pickup game like
I would I'm there I was playing five six
times a week for a while and then I
ruptured my Achilles tendon playing on
an Oregon Beach with students a few
years ago I'm not doing that anymore
yeah but biking which I love and I find
meditative I have a very hard time
convincing myself to get on my bike
even though while I'm doing it I love it
and after I do it I feel better and I'm
more productive and I'm more creative
and I just you know more in love with
life but it's a pain in the ass and it's
a little bit physically uncomfortable
and you know all of these things are
true we we prioritize the the pleasure
of now over even something that for me I
know not it's not even that I'm gonna
feel better after I did it I actually
love the activity itself mm-hmm but
getting over that sort of activation
energy to do the thing and I suspect
that sport like actual team sports is a
little bit different a little different
like you're ready to go you're ready to
go I go people are there I'm ready Oh
like let's yeah but going in the gym I
would like into that like I know that
when I work out I like doing it and I
feel great after but it's like oh I
gotta get in my car I got a drive over
there I got a park feels like a chore
yeah yeah but you yet you know it's good
and yet so we're always fighting our
nature sort of is we are no it's exactly
we're always fighting our nature and it
shouldn't surprise us that we're gonna
need to fight our nature with regard to
responding to the Internet and
responding to especially especially the
little computers we carry around in our
pockets and learning to restrict our
access to those training ourselves to
restrict our access to those I think
anyone with the ability to train
themselves to meditate or to do anything
on a regular basis should should be able
to train themselves that same way with
regard to devices yeah all right well
we've done about an hour here and I'm
gonna demand that you come back because
I know I know we can do way more that's
unfortunate just because my schedule is
so nuts at the moment we have to kind of
stop but can you give me one more thing
that you're just really excited
right now that you've been thinking
about or working on or anything else
that's really just giving you a little
bit a little bit of juice at the moment
while you're in this interesting space
for yourself well there are a number of
things I guess there's a there's a piece
I wrote a number of years ago that is
supposed to be out in the literary
magazine just about now-ish
about having been mugged at knifepoint
in Quito one of these on one of these
study abroad trips which prompted I was
with three students
where's Quito at the capital of Ecuador
okay so it was it was the very it was
before the first day of one of my
six-week study abroad trips so 20
students just mean Brett wasn't there on
this one and the experience in which you
know we've been we've been to get the
three students and I've been together
all day we come to the top of the stairs
and suddenly two guys with with knives
run around the corner and pinned me and
my female student up against a wall and
do this sort of knife dance in front of
us and then relieve I didn't have
anything on me because I know how to
walk around Latin American cities and
one of my students didn't but two of my
students had all of their stuff taken
off them including this really nice DSLR
that that Michelle my student had and
they run off and the next thing I
realize I am on one of these guys in the
middle of the street pulling on the
backpack he's stolen from another one of
my students another one of my students
has chased down the other guy Wow
and I thought how did that happen and
why is everything now so loud and so
colorful and I thought back immediately
thought wow the entire experience that I
just had was somehow in black and white
and was without sound and so I mean it's
an interesting long story that that I
basically explored in this essay by
going and doing doing a dive into the
literature on the nature of memory and
the nature of sensory memory in
particular and what it is that we can
and cannot perceive in the moment what
our brains take in why time seems to
slow down so just to go back to our
earlier version about time
YTN time seems to slow down in periods
of intensity it's not that it time slows
down but basically our frame rate
increases and not only our frame rate
increases but the amount that we
remember and you know move into
short-term memory and then in this case
into long-term memory increases so this
is this is one of the things that I've
been thinking about lately in sort of
how how memory and the senses and in
fact how all of us are a little bit of
synesthetes are experiencing our world
in ways that that we don't usually have
language for not that it was the purpose
of the story but how did this all end it
ended we got we got the stuff back well
um we got the stuff back and as soon as
the student Jeremy and I gave chase
these guys and got the stuff back then
the police showed up then the concert
stopped lured up from there and and the
whole way I they were watching I it was
it was remarkable actually was total
there was no one on this walk we'd seen
no one
these two guys run up to us mug us run
off we give chase and then the entire
neighborhood comes alive suddenly there
were hundreds of people there like where
were you got it
there's some sort of study to be done on
that well I'm sure they've done Studies
on that you know when people see a bad
thing happening but nobody calls the
police all that kind of stuff
well if it's been an absolute pleasure
I'm so glad that we finally got to do
this in person and we will do it again
and you guys can follow Heather on the
Twitter she does tweet a decent amount
but not a unhealthy addicted about I
would say it's at Heather II I
[Music]
you